Ben Higgins the next Bachelor  well maybe Ben speaks to et exclusively  about the rumors the reality star who  was sent home by Kaitlyn on Monday  night's episode says quote those  conversations haven't happened yet with  ABC he tells ET the opportunity is a  great one and from a 30,000 foot view I  would have to consider it and I would  love to be able to share life longer  with you but that's not gonna happen and  that will be tough  ABC isn't yet commenting on the identity  of the next Bachelor it's usually  officially revealed in the wake of the  after the final rose episode and that  won't air until Monday July 20th but  would you approve of then as the next  Bachelor  if not who would you choose after this  wild season Nick I'm totally in love  with you but more than I can even say in  words so hmm let us know who ABC should  go with on Twitter use the hashtag ET  now  you